l'eau bienvenue ce nouvel les premiers
épisodes du coup de fil alors qu'est ce
que le coup de fil c'est des podcasts
vidéo qui ont pour but d'initier à la
philo mais d'une manière un peu plus
faible que d'habitude et comme c'est la
première vidéo est peut-être la dernière
ça va dépendre de son succès on va
traiter quelque chose qui est
fondamentale en philosophie c'est
l'allégorie de la caverne par platon
pourquoi la question c'est qui platon le
chien unique est à une planète du
système solaire
un poisson le ton quant à elle à 10,1
platon platon c'est le disciple de
socrate et ce grâce à un peu l'inventeur
de la tous philosophie platon c'est un
philosophe de la grèce antique et comme
tous les philosophes ils s'attaquaient à
plein d'idées plein de concept avant
même d'attaquer tout ça il se demande
lui c'est quoi une idée donc est ce qu
un concept philosophique après tout est
ce qu'un et ron ne serait pas un trône
électronique et la seconde un truc aussi
toute notre vie on a vu un lit en bois
et bien sûr montrent un lien au métal on
va reconnaître que cinq témoins mondiale
alors que quand on nous expliquait pour
la première fois ce que c'était un ami
vous a pas dit toutes les sortes délits
possibles
et pourtant on reconnaît un lit quand il
est différent du sien du coup
heureusement qu'on a des idées quoi vous
imaginez genre un monde sans idée oui
bonjour je m'appelle marcel et je vous
appelle pour une erreur sur notre
catalogue en fait dans la section lit
l'article flück il a en métal et
novembre c'est par nico en lice et en
bois bah je vous en prie merci et
georgette gérant avoir fait une bonne
action
on met tous en ce monde réel sensorielle
avec des idées qui sont identiques à
chacun
mais une question qui se pose d'où
viennent les idées et la plata pour lui
les idées elles viennent du monde des
idées
en fait c'est un peu comme s'il disait
dans ton cul mais en mode d'antiquités
donc c'est pour ça que le caca et l'idée
la plus attendre quoi polystyrène quoi
elles sont les idées en fait est souvent
le monde des idées voilà elles sont dans
le monde des idées on peut revenir sur
le cac a maintenant ça intéresse
quelqu'un
kaka en fait à la naissance notre esprit
avant d'arriver dans notre corps il
passe par le monde décide dans le monde
des idées il ya l'idée parfaite de lit
qui coexiste avec l'idée parfaite de
chien puisque existe avec les départs
fait de stylos en passant par le monde
des idées l'esprit s'imprègne de toutes
les cités parfaite il est parfaite de
lits deux chiens de stylos mais aussi de
liberté égalité fraternité quand il
arrive dans le corps à la naissance mais
du coup il a déjà toutes les idées en
place
mais si leurs résidents parce qu'il sait
déjà tout alors le gars moi que je suis
ne charrie pas tout blanc talus
excellente remarque un peu les idées à
son gala mais on n'en a pas conscience
vous n'avez jamais eu cette sensation on
vous explique un truc en fait vous avez
juste l'impression qu'on vous le
rappelle est que vous le saviez déjà
on se met jamais ça pour platon ça
s'appelle la réminiscence
on ne sait quoi leur rapport à devoir
cavernes t'as vu en fait platon
symbolise tout ça avec l'image d'une
caverne
en gros on serait tout cela avec des
chaînes en face d'un mur dans le noir
tous ensemble alan genre des grecs des
grecs ensemble dans une soirée l'a1 dans
la caverne et personne ne se doute de
rien je prends un teubé et sur le mur
vers des ombres parce que derrière une
grosse ligne est mal aux yeux et entre
nous et la lumière des gens qui passent
avec des objets par exemple un stylo
et ce stylo ce stylo c'est l'idée
parfaite de stylos ce qui est projeté
sur le mur
c'est juste une ombre de cette idée
parfaite et c'est ce que nous on voit en
fait au quotidien boys
ce stylo là par exemple que je tiens là
dans ma chambre dans le monde et elle
sait que l'ombre d'eux l'idée parfaite
du sinon pourquoi c'est pas l'idée
parfaite du silo bat déjà parce qu'il
est oui et des parfums du stylo ni bleus
moi ni rouge ni quadricolor quadricolor
ce cap il a 4 ou 4 couleurs ils sont
quatre couleurs quadricolor allemagne
c'est joli ça c'est juste une ombre de
l'idée parfaite de stylos donc nous on
serait là on verrait des ombres qui sont
en fait ce qu'on voit dans la vie réelle
est derrière nous il se passe là-bas
actions avec les idées parfaite le
combler concept etc du coup pourquoi on
se retourne pas pour aller voir ce qui
se passe parce que mon gars dès que tu
te retournes je reçois tellement de
lumière dans la gueule ça fait trop
halle aux yeux sauf une personne où ça
les idées
ce qui arrive à se retourner et à
regarder les idées en face c'est eux les
philosophes à pour ce soit un peu plus
clair parce que c'est un peu chaud vous
aimez un schéma pour peut-être nous
comprendre nous on est là prisonniers
dans la caverne et on voit des ombres de
forme d'objet ici c'est le chemin pour
aller au monde des idées
donc on voit que les philosophes sont
dans ce chemin et là en haut et on voit
le monde des idées
donc là où il y aurait l'idée parfaite
de chiens de ligne de stylos par exemple
et pour accéder au monde des idées ça se
fait par un seul chemin
la raison pour que pour vous l'allégorie
de la caverne est maintenant un peu plus
clair c'était le premier épisode d'un
coup de fil on se retrouve une prochaine
fois pour un prochain épisode
yann moix